.
Okay, der Titel dieses
Videos ist insofern irreführend,
weil ich derzeit gerade nicht
genau weiß, wie groß mein Baby ist.
Wenn ihr euch fragt, Moment mal,
habe ich was verpasst?
Nein, das hier ist meine Art euch
zu sagen, dass ich schwanger bin.
Hallo!
11,5 cm ist so
ein Durchschnittswert.
Ich werde es erst beim
nächsten Ultraschall genau wissen.
Es könnten auch schon 14 cm sein,
was mich gar nicht wundern würde.
Das können wir doch messen.
92 cm.
Puh!
Ich wollte ein Video darüber machen.
Nicht nur, weil ich es
nicht mehr lange verstecken kann,
sondern auch, um euch zu erzählen,
wie die letzten Monate waren
und was jetzt noch kommt.
Und was das alles
für den Kanal maiLab bedeutet.
Morgen,
wenn dieses Video herauskommt,
fängt mein 5. Monat an.
D.h., ich habe
schon einiges hinter mir.
Die ersten drei Monate der
Schwangerschaft sind sehr aufregend,
aber auch ein bisschen doof.
Vielen Frauen geht es in diesem
ersten Trimester ziemlich schlecht.
Körperlich, der Körper
macht extreme Veränderungen durch.
Nicht nur, dass da jetzt ein Mensch,
ein freaking Mensch
da in meinem Bauch ist,
dass ich gerade zwei Menschen bin,
sondern es verändert sich alles.
Von deiner Haut,
über die Pigmentierung.
Ich habe in dieser Zeit gerade
10 % mehr Blut in meinem Körper.
Es sind bei mir über 300 ml.
Moment ...
Nur mal zur Visualisierung:
So viel mehr an Blut habe
ich gerade in meinem Körper.
Bis zum Ende der Schwangerschaft
wird mein Blutvolumen
um 50 % steigen.
Es passieren so viele
abgefahrene Dinge mit meinem Körper.
Dann natürlich noch die
ganzen Schwangerschaftshormone,
mit denen man sich bisher im Leben
noch nie herumschlagen musste,
also noch nie in diesem Ausmaß.
Nur ein Beispiel: das sogn.
HCG-Hormon, also das Hormon,
was auch auf den Schwanger-
schaftstest detektiert wird,
steigt in der Schwangerschaft
um das 40.000-50.000 fache an.
Es ist doch rein wissenschaftlich,
medizinisch sehr spannend,
was gerade alles passiert.
Ich hab mir zum Einstieg ein
Taschenbuch "Embryologie" gekauft.
Manche Medizinstudenten
haben das im Studium.
Ich kann es nicht empfehlen.
Ich zeige euch
das ein bisschen weiter weg,
ich will euch nicht verstören,
aber es sind unglaublich
viele unschöne Bilder drin,
von Fällen,
was auch alles schiefgehen kann.
Solche Bilder möchte man als
werdende Mutter einfach nicht sehen.
Es ist ein bisschen brutal,
aber die Informationen,
die da drinstehen,
sind wenigstens verifiziert.
Dafür bin ich dann doch
ganz dankbar, weil ihr wisst es ja,
wie das ist im Internet.
Da gibt es eine Fülle an
Informationen und man weiß nie,
ob sie stimmen.
All diese Veränderungen im Körper
kommen nicht ohne Nebenwirkungen.
Man kennt die
berühmte "Morgenübelkeit",
die bei den meisten nicht
nur morgens ist, sondern immer.
Die Liste der
Beschwerden ist vielfältig.
Ich hatte auf
ziemlich schwere Bauchschmerzen.
Nach dem Essen hatte
ich Verdauungsprobleme.
Ich war extrem, extrem müde.
Wer mir näher folgt,
der hat schon mitbekommen,
dass sich ein eigentlich
ziemlich busy Leben habe.
Ich arbeite sehr viel,
die Arbeit macht sehr viel Spaß.
Ich habe häufig 16 Stunden Tage.
Ich schlafe ziemlich wenig.
Das hat sich alles
sehr schlagartig geändert.
Ich muss am
Anfang der Schwangerschaft
manchmal nach dem Frühstück
direkt wieder schlafen gehen.
Eigentlich bin ich ganz dankbar,
dass das Kleine mich erfolgreich
gezwungen hat, mehr zu schlafen.
Schlaf ist sehr gesund,
wie wir wissen.
Spätestens seit
unserem Video zum Schlafentzug.
Ausgerechnet in diesen ersten
drei Monaten, wo so viel los ist,
kannst du niemanden davon erzählen.
Zumindest wird das empfohlen, dass
man dass die ersten drei Monate,
also im ersten Trimester low hält,
weil das Risiko für eine
Fehlgeburt da noch recht hoch ist.
Klar, wenn dann
doch irgendwas schiefgeht,
dann möchtest du halt nicht,
dass die ganze Welt davon weiß.
Man hat dann
halt dieses riesige Geheimnis,
was manche nur
schwer geheimhalten können.
Z.B., wenn Sie
jeden Tag kotzen müssen.
Wir hatten das Glück,
habt ihr ja mitbekommen,
dass wir den letzten Monat
meines ersten Trimesters weg waren.
Wir waren vier Wochen in den USA.
So musste ich mir nicht jeden Tag
eine Ausrede einfallen lassen,
warum ich nicht arbeite kann, weil
ich den ganzen Tag schlafen muss.
Mir gehts jetzt viel besser,
Gott sei Dank.
Wie bei den meisten Frauen
ist das zweite Trimester deutlich
entspannter als das erste.
Ich habe nicht dieselbe Power
wie vor der Schwangerschaft,
das merke ich schon deutlich.
Das fällt mir auch
nicht schwer zu akzeptieren.
Das ist jetzt erst einmal
das Wichtigste hier drin.
Eine Konsequenz daraus habt
ihr vielleicht schon festgestellt:
Seit einiger Zeit kommen
die Videos auf diesem Kanal
nicht immer strikt jeden Donnerstag,
sondern vielleicht auch
erst freitags oder sonntags.
Das wird auch erst
einmal so weitergehen.
Ich versuche das
möglichst entspannt zu halten.
Vor der Schwangerschaft
habe ich sehr gerne
mal eine Nachtschicht eingelegt,
damit das Video
noch rechtzeitig kommt.
Die Arbeit macht recht viel Spaß,
aber das mache
ich natürlich jetzt nicht mehr.
Ich passe auf mich auf und ich weiß,
dass jeder super supportiv seid.
Danke auch dafür und
jetzt wisst ihr so auch Bescheid.
Wie geht es sonst hier weiter?
maiLab wird kein Baby-Kanal,
keine Sorge.
Hier wird es so weitergehen,
wie bisher,
mit guten
wissenschaftlichen Themen.
Wir haben einiges auf der Liste.
Ihr könnt auch gerne
in die Kommentare schreiben,
was euch so einfällt.
Soviel zu meinem Update.
Damit ist es jetzt ganz offiziell
und ich muss es jetzt
vor niemanden mehr verstecken.
Wir sehen uns
in ungefähr einer Woche.
Bis dahin, bleibt sicher.
Untertitel: ARD Text
im Auftrag von Funk 2019